m e thierry va là bonjour et merci
d'être en direct avec nous alors mettre
en place un moratoire sur la vente de
logiciels espions pour garantir les
droits humains on vient de voir c'est
l'objectif de l'onu l'organisation qui
souhaite sur le long terme fixé un cadre
réglementaire c'est une tâche compliquée
à mettre en place selon vous
c'est une tâche qui est extrêmement
compliqué à mettre en place puisque il
est clair que la coopération en matière
de défense ou la malle à la coopération
en matière de surveillance de
cyberdéfense on va dire et à mon avis
totalement illusoire
ce qui change dans la sphère pegasus par
rapport aux règles de ce cyber
surveillance habituelle qui sont faites
de d'état c'est que il s'agit d'une
société privée séné soldes d'été
israélienne qui qui vend ses ces
logiciels espions spyware qui sont
extrêmement efficaces
comment arriver à contrecarrer la vente
et la diffusion de ce type de dispositif
ad normalement uniquement à des à des
états mais qui peuvent tout à fait être
m en instance être vendus étaient à tout
un chacun on peut qu'il ait quelques
millions de dollars sous la main je ne
vois pas du tout une coopération
internationale sinon de façade qui est
qui pourrait prévenir ce type de ce type
de diffusion et de vente et justement
comment est ce que ces entreprises
surveillance agissent aujourd'hui
impunément comme ça
elle dit elle dispose de
[Musique]
d'éléments extrêmement
efficace et intrusif et surtout discret
la grande fiabilité de pegasus tient au
fait que c'est ce qu'on appelle des
exploitent des failles zero day donc qui
permettent donc il est cédé faille dans
le code de programmation de votre
smartphone cela soit sous android ou ce
soit sous sous ios et les apple pour
permettre de de pénétrer dans le dans
votre téléphone sans aucune manipulation
extérieure c'est à dire que d'habitude
vous fait entrer le logiciel en appuyant
sur un lien qui est envoyé par un mail
ou par un ou par sms là pas du tout
c'est ce qu'on appelle le zéro clic et
vous avez donc une quelqu'un qui va
rentrer dans votre ordinateur sans roue
dans roue dans votre smartphone sans que
vous en aperceviez il peut même le
détruire à distance donc on a on a une
extrême discrétion de ce type de
logiciel et dont on ne sait pas
d'ailleurs on le voit bien avec pegasus
seas a fonctionné pendant des années les
années et ce heureusement que amnesty
international a pu faire son enquête et
a tu veux déceler avec grande difficulté
ce cesser ces comportements totalement
scandaleux
avec après quelques années donc on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a une véritable île
véritable impunité presque de de c2c
organiste l'organisme qui qui permet qui
peuvent réagir je peux dire en toute
impunité mais presque et donc il faut
véritablement qu'il y à une prise de
conscience elle j'espère que cette
affaire pegasus aux aurores on sera un
exemple pour les décideurs les membres
des gouvernements a dû à l'utiliser des
systèmes à minima sécurisé de ne pas
utiliser leur smartphone par exemple
habituel mais d'avoir justement d'avoir
recours à des logiciels aussi qui
permettent de le prévenir et de déceler
ce type d'intrusion mais ça c'est ça
c'est véritablement tout une une défense
on va dire individuel et au niveau des
gouvernements après ça c'est pour les
gouvernements malheureusement sur ce
type de dispositif on s'aperçoit qu'ils
sont également utilisés pour espionner
pour surveiller des journalistes des
avocats des droits de l'hommistes donc
beaucoup moins de 2 des d'éléments pour
pouvoir assurer leur défense et c'est
bien ça qui m'inquiète alors
concrètement qu'est ce qu'il faut
aujourd'hui pour lutter contre leurs
pratiques les sanctionner restreindre
leur champ d'action ou mettre en place à
des organes de contrôle
mettre en place des organes de contrôle
pourquoi pas mais on sait très bien que
l'équipe 1 je répète mon avis totalement
totalement illusoire je crois qu'il faut
véritablement qu'on arrive aujourd'hui à
avoir au sein
ddd gouvernement et en europe notamment
des organismes qui soit beaucoup plus
efficace au niveau de la cyberdéfense
qui soit beaucoup plus axé sur
l'utilisation
de ce type de dispositif en dehors des
utilisations qui sont normalement les
siennes qui c'est celle de surveillance
des terroristes était l'un des membres
du crime organisé donc il faut
véritablement une prise de conscience
par rapport à par rapport à
l'utilisation de ces technologies qui
sont aujourd'hui
extrêmement efficace et qui est et qui
fonctionne je crois que essayer de les
contrôler par par le biais d'un de ce
moratoire par exemple tenu propose c'est
un voeu pieux et malheureusement je
crois qu'il n'y a qu'une une véritable
organisation de cyberdéfense altérer
leur dette de chaque état qui pourra
permettre de véritablement contrecarrer
l'utilisation qui restera de toute façon
utilisée de deux de ce type de
dispositif par des des officines peu
scrupuleuses qu'ils voteront à qui veut
bien l'acheter merci beaucoup en tout
cas thierry valade avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat au barreau de paris